[Music]
okay I've been running around comic-con
just trying to find all my Power Rangers
all my oh geez and I found another one
well it's for having such a good scent
about here you guys with the og Power
Rangers interact with fans like I've
never seen I mean you guys to a lot of
people are the most famous people in
this room yet you just sit here interact
very humble very down-to-earth I mean
what does that mean to you you know it's
it's probably the biggest blessing that
we have I mean I pretty much anywhere I
go I always get loved up and I have like
instant family so I love that yeah and
everybody shares like these really
personal stories about how Power Rangers
yeah I mean and it's it's so diversified
it can be anything from you know people
that learn martial arts to people being
homeless and it was the thing they saw
on TV that got them through their day
and and they remember that and they come
back and they tell me man you got me you
helped me get through it you know or we
there's a lot of people we just inspired
to be better people you know so that's
awesome do you feel like that's why cuz
you know you see a lot of cast that they
really want to let go of what you know
that the first thing they did they're
like I'm not that character but you guys
really embrace it why do you think that
is I think maybe because yeah it the
fact that it is such a positive thing
it's been such a positive looking for
people in their lives and I mean I've
done a lot of work other than Power
Rangers but I don't think I've done
anything that has as much merchandise
like it's continuously following me
between the comic books and the video
games and and everything else it's like
I you know it just it's everywhere so
yeah and I'm happy about it cuz coolest
likes it it's kind of nice to see my
image 25 years later and another
something another comic book another
poster
exact everything same well you know Zack
don't crack so we are on the 25th
anniversary of Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers we've got the original cast all
going to these conventions all embracing
their characters all loving it so why
how do we get like a reboot or a revival
or a reunion you know I think I think
the fans are gonna have to call for it I
mean they are calling it has to happen I
don't know why it hasn't happened yet
but you know we are all like you know
we're all here so yeah we can make it
happen and you know I think that I think
personally I think a marketing
opportunity was missed because we could
have been pepper dogs to that movie the
last movie that is my biggest pet peeve
another I mean I I could have been a
security guy going hey come back here
you know anything just a cameo for all
of our fans from 25 years I know you
want to cater to the audience but you
know we got a lot of people that we left
behind so I completely agree with you
and I think they should have peppered
you guys in as like Canon yeah just you
know they have Jason amy-jo in there and
that was great but they weren't playing
their character no no like they were
standardized big issue for me as well so
if you guys did do a reunion what would
that look like or what would you want to
say I definitely would want to see our
stories continued and complete it like I
went out to a peace treaty and I don't
know where I am now so although you know
what's interesting is what Boone Comics
is doing they got the shattered grin and
all the stories are coming up with our
amazing I think it's it's that kind of
stuff is what our our older friends
don't really love to see kind of happen
with us if people aren't reading that
like that is a great great way to see
what amazing what became of your ranger
yeah yeah I mean like the stories
there's three comic books so there's
bull gumming books the Power Rangers
there's go-go Rangers which has kind of
covers us as our teenage selves and then
there's the shattered grid which is just
going to socks up everybody and now we
just got to get you guys back on the
screen yes we got to find the rest
we gotta figure out what that's gonna be
hashtag bring them back bring them back
but we got that's the Power Rangers okay
we got a workshop now we gotta work when
we get out there well thank you so much
for letting us come by chat with you
it's over Lucy I'm putting on my real
[Music]
[Applause]